really nice coffee shop but i also
remember that was the first time i went
horseback riding yes with your family oh
i have a story about this yeah
so we went to hawaii
we were in kauai and i had never i have
like no horse experience whatsoever i
didn't grow up riding horses didn't grow
up around them at all
but this guy goes we should go horseback
riding he's like i'm a horseman
he's like i used to go
she's like i used to go with sarah
to her hometown in louisville and just
ride horses all day
for like months so he really made it out
like he was some [ __ ] cowboy right
sarah he couldn't even mount the horse
he couldn't even swing his tiny little
legs over a short horse
and i and this horse nearly trampled him
to death
like it was the funniest thing and then
he the amount of times you knew you
almost got like bucked off because the
horse just [ __ ] hated you yeah i was
like this guy's a [ __ ] liar you
didn't go riding horses with sarah she
probably rode horses i rode the horses
i rode a horse
was that your first time though
[Laughter]
what story
go ahead
okay
what story what story
i went horseback riding with the family
so aggressive no i
didn't say he did ride horses
he i didn't you did but you didn't tell
them
when bobby but no the whole story is
when
go
go ahead go ahead
hey
when we first went there okay so
there's something about horses if you
don't know so there's like
normal sized horses for norm
no like you know like yeah 15 hands yeah
like big horses
but there's also ponies called shetland
punk i know sheldon's pennies so uh-huh
cute little where we went to rut he did
he did go to ride he we did he we went
to oldham county yeah and you rode at
debbie's farm in debbie's farm and so we
went to go get the horse
did you write a shetland poem
tell the story right
go ahead
what happened this wedding what is it so
no so we went we're walking towards the
barn
we're walking towards the barn yeah
debbie goes let me go get the horses for
everybody
so it's me
my mom
she brings out one horse normal horse
yeah
two horse normal horses
three
[Laughter]
look like a dog
they used to do tricks like that all the
time and they usually used to laugh and
laugh and laugh
and they laughed
oh god i remember that that was your
horse riding no i didn't actually got on
a regular one after after that yeah that
was a joke
and then there's a 10-minute 15-minute
laugh killed it again right and i'm like
i'm mugging you i mean surprise
[Laughter]
right and then i get on a regular horse
but yeah i do remember that yeah yeah
and then and then we
[Laughter]
and then we were
thank you black and white
um so yeah we were riding so in oldham
county and so the surrounding counties
of kentucky are all like rural woodsy
[ __ ]
so we're riding through the woods
and every other tree
pavika is that where they hang
[Laughter]
i remember also they wrote an article
about us they did in the in the
newspaper my parents have it and i hope
this isn't i mean it's all like it's
been girl it's been here but they still
have that framed it's down in our
basement we i still have a picture of
the both of you framed yeah up on our
wall
yeah and i know that sounds really weird
but i really have like
you know when i first met bobby one of
the things that i was so scared of
finding out about him was that his exes
were
i mean that's all women are wonderful
i'm just saying like
it would have been a red flag for me if
his ex wasn't you like when he told me
about you when he says this is sarah
she's a comedian she's funny she's